le commerce international accru et le
réchauffement climatique profita des
indésirables les insectes ravageurs
souvent en provenance de pays exotiques
il bouleverse nos écosystèmes est l'un
des exemples les plus connus
c'est l'agrile du frêne un coléoptère
envahissant qui est venu d'asie ont soit
quatrièmement soir céline et 200000
fresnes à montréal et la ville est
partie en guerre et prend les grands
moyens
oui on a annoncé ce matin un budget de
18 millions de dollars pour lutter
contre l'agrile du frêne et planter des
arbres pour vous donner une idée l'année
dernière c'était près 13 millions de
dollars dont une nette augmentation
cet argent là va servir à abattre les
arbres qu'on ne peut pas sauver a
inoculé à vacciner en fait ce qu'ils
peuvent toujours l'être 200 $ par arbre
ça doit être renouvelé à tous les deux
ans ce traitement là et l'argent sert
aussi à augmenter la forêt urbaine a
planté massivement on n'a jamais planté
autant d'arbres à montréal donc on
n'investit plus le problème c'est ce que
mentionner les représentants de
l'opposition aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a
peut-être trop attendu la situation
serait hors de contrôle selon
l'opposition on a détecté effectivement
beaucoup plus d'armes infectés à
l'automne 2015 que l'année précédente
depuis quatre ans là ce sont 13 ulf
rennes qui ont dû être abattus dans mon
quartier par exemple ya pleins d'à qu'on
est en train de couper dans une
situation qui est assez dramatique mais
ce cas pas des leçons justement à tirer
de ça va être la fin de la monoculture
on ne verra plus des quartiers entiers
où on ne voit qu'une seule sorte
d'essence d'armes
il faut une la biodiversité maintenant
c'est clair il faudra aussi repenser la
façon de planter parce que dans la
nature les arbres ne poussent pas tous
seuls à une distance égale il pousse en
gros ils s'entraident ans a été prouvé
donc on va vouloir les regrouper de plus
en plus quand c'est possible
phénomène intéressant aussi céline on
est en train de repenser la façon de
voir les armes
réal ménard de la ville de montréal a
dit ce sont des actifs capitalisables on
n'aurait pas entendu seuil à 10 15 ans
là donc ils nous rendent des services
purifient l'air il nous a aidé à gérer
les eaux pluviales et on est en train
d'y reconnaître là pour l'euro
qu'il joue dans les villes mais il ya la
grève du frêne ne sais pas le seul
insecte qui pourrait faire des ravages
et clément on parle beaucoup des villes
mais les acériculteurs notamment
surveille de près le longicorne
asiatique qui s'attaque aux érables à
sucre notamment et à d'autres feuillus
l'acériculture évidemment est évalué à
plusieurs centaines de millions de
dollars
ici au canada cet insecte là pourrait
faire des ravages il a été détecté une
première fois en 2003 à toronto en
france l avoir éradiqué mais il est
réapparu en 2013 pas de signalement
encore au québec mais il faut rester
vigilant faut surveiller sa merci
beaucoup catherine l'entrée